[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con no nos
acompaña a karina gould ministra del
desarrollo internacional de canadá país
que será anfitrión de la conferencia
internacional de donantes en solidaridad
con los refugiados inmigrantes
venezolanos ministra gol gracias por
estar con nosotros en france 24 muy buen
día empiezo por preguntarle cuáles son
los propósitos de este encuentro que
tendrá lugar el próximo mes
primero buenos días y muchas gracias por
tenerme hoy este esperamos este mantener
en enfoque sobre la crisis de la
migración venezolana en la región apoyar
a los países es este acogiendo a que
reciben a los migrantes y recaudar aún
más fondos para apoyar este los países
que reciben migrantes
la recepción de migrantes y también para
los servicios sociales que tienen su
propio país ministra go de más de 5
millones de venezolanos han huido de la
crisis social y política en su nación
más allá de estas ayudas económicas que
otras necesidades inmediatas tienen
estos migrantes claro pues este muchos o
sea como ustedes saben han perdido sus
trabajos tienen este dificultades de
integrarse a la economía pero también la
crisis sanitaria
les impacta mucho también y toda la
cuestión del estatus legal que tienen en
los países este donde se encuentran
ahorita es algo muy importante y
reconocemos mucho al gobierno de
colombia quien ha dado y brindado hace
10 años de estatus de protección
temporal a los migrantes venezolanos y
sabemos que otros países en la región
están en proceso de regularizar este los
migrantes de los órganos que encuentran
en sus países también y por ahí va mi
tercera pregunta ministra porque le
quiero preguntar si se plantea aquí
entonces recaudar fondos también para
otros países como colombia perú o chile
que reciben la mayor carga migratoria de
venezuela
si la idea es de la conferencia es
realmente este recaudar fondos para los
países que cosas son los que han
recibido los migrantes este tanto como
colombia perú ecuador pero también este
chile bolivia en muchos países en
centroamérica y el caribe o sea y
realmente ósea enseñar al mundo que
tanto está haciendo la región para
recibir esos migrantes este darles la
bienvenida en su país y tratar realmente
de entregar / integrarlos este pues es
la crisis migratoria
este segundo más importante en el mundo
después de la crisis migratorio de siria
pero estar este por este año tal vez lo
va a pasar por los números de personas
inmigrantes que están saliendo de
venezuela y llegando a países este
vecinos en la región ministro también se
estima que en que nada haya
aproximadamente más de 20 mil
venezolanos le pregunto qué requisitos y
programas de acogida tiene el gobierno
canadiense para estar
son las pues en canadá hasta cuando
recibí esta tenemos un problema muy
grande de inmigración cada año a más de
400.000 personas que vienen de todas
partes del mundo y cuando llegan aquí o
sea les damos apoyo
con este clases del lenguaje sean inglés
o francés depende de dónde están
ubicados en en canadá a apoyos es para
encontrar trabajos este y este acceso al
sistema de salud cuando vienen de manera
regular pero también recibimos
refugiados que están designados por el
acnur oeste la organización
internacional de inmigración también
minimizó el gobierno de venezuela se
mostró ahora dispuesto a dialogar con la
oposición tras la propuesta del líder
juan guaidó el diario de oposición juan
guaidó que considera estos diálogos
pueden le pregunto si considera que
estos diálogos pueden ayudar de alguna
manera a solucionar esta crisis
migratoria que vive venezuela
mirar la crisis migratoria de venezuela
es un resultado de la crisis política
que encuentra en el país en este momento
osaka nada sigue apoyando el diábolo y
un retorno a la democracia entonces
claro que damos la bienvenida de esas
conversaciones porque al final o sea de
todo eso la única manera que eso va a
ser solucionado es una solución política
es de que tiene que llevar a cabo
adentro de venezuela misma
y asegurar que esté el gobierno está
respondiendo a las necesidades de su
gente entonces esté claro este esperamos
que ese diálogo llegar a un regreso o un
retorno a la democracia en venezuela
ministra gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en france 24 feel resto de
día ustedes también gracias continúan
con nosotros
[Música]